when i look in the mirror today
i see a justice an education scholar at
columbia university
a youth mentor an activist
and a future new york state senator
i see all of that and a man who spent
a quarter of his life in state prison
six years to be exact starting as a
teenager
on rikers island for an act that nearly
cost a man his life
but what got me from there to here
was it the punishment i faced as a
teenager in adult prison
or the harshness of our legal system
instead it was a learning environment of
a classroom
that introduced me to something i didn't
think was possible for me
or our justice system as a whole
a few weeks before my release on parole
a counselor encouraged me to enroll in a
new
college course being offered in a prison
it was called inside criminal justice
that seems pretty straightforward though
right well it turns out
the class will be made up of eight
incarcerated men
and eight assistant district attorneys
columbia university psychology professor
geraldine downey
and manhattan assistant d.a lucy lang
co-taught the course
and it was the first of its kind i can
honestly say
this wasn't how i imagined starting
college
my mind was blown from day one i assumed
all the prosecutors in the room would be
white
but i remember walking into the room on
the first day of class
and seeing three black prosecutors and
thinking to myself
wow being a black prosecutor
that's a thing
by the end of the first session i was
all in in fact
a few weeks after my release i found
myself doing something i prayed
i wouldn't i walked right back into
prison
but thankfully this time i was just as a
student
to join my fellow classmates
and this time i got to go home when
class was over
in the next session we talked about what
had brought each of us to this point of
our lives and into the classroom
together
i eventually got comfortable enough to
reveal my truth to everyone in the room
about where i came from
i talked about how my sisters and i
watched our mother
suffer years of abuse at the hands of
our stepfather
escaping only to find ourselves living
in a shelter
i talked about how i swore nope to my
family
to keep them safe i even explained how i
didn't feel like a teenager at 13
but more like a soldier on a mission and
like any soldier
this meant carrying an emotional burden
on my shoulders
and i hate to say it but a gun on my
waist
and just a few days after my 17th
birthday that mission completely failed
as my sister and i were walking to the
laundromat a crowd stopped in front of
us
two girls out of nowhere attacked my
sister still confused about what was
happening i tried to pull one girl away
and just as i did i felt something brush
across my face
with my adrenaline rushing i didn't
realize a man had leaped out of the
crowd and cut me
as i felt warm blood oozed down my face
and watching him raise his knife toward
me again
i turned to defend myself and pull that
gun
from my waistband and squeeze the
trigger
thankfully he didn't lose his life that
day
my hands shaking and heart racing i was
paralyzed in fear
from that moment i felt regret
that would never leave me
i learned later on they attacked my
sister in the case of mistaken identity
thinking she was someone else it was
terrifying
but clear that i wasn't trained nor was
i qualified
to be the soldier that i thought i
needed to be
but in my neighborhood i only felt safe
carrying a weapon now back in the
classroom
after hearing my story the prosecutors
could tell i never wanted to hurt anyone
i just wanted us to make it home
i could literally see the gradual change
in each of their faces
as they heard story after story from the
other incarcerated men in the room
stories that have trapped many of us
within the vicious cycle of
incarceration
that most haven't been able to break
free of
and sure there are people
who can make terrible crimes but the
stories
of these individuals lives before they
commit those acts
were the kinds of stories these
prosecutors had never heard
and when it was their turn to speak the
prosecutors i was surprised too
they weren't emotionless drones or
robocops pre-programmed to send people
to prison
they were sons and daughters
brothers and sisters
but most of all they were good students
they were ambitious
and motivated and they believed that
they could use the power of law
to protect people they wanted a mission
that i could definitely understand
midway through the course nick a fellow
incarcerated student
poured out his concern that the
prosecutors were tiptoeing around the
racial bias
and discrimination within our criminal
justice system
now if you've ever been to prison you
will know it's impossible to talk about
justice reform
without talking about race so we
silently cheered for nick
and we're eager to hear the prosecutor's
response and no
i don't remember who spoke first but
when chauncey parker
the senior prosecutor agreed with nick
and said he was committed
to ending the mass incarceration of
people of color
i believed him and i knew we were
heading in the right direction
we now started to move as a team we
started exploring new possibilities
and uncovering a truce about our justice
system
and how real change happens for us
for me it wasn't the mandatory programs
inside of the prison instead
it was listening to the advice of elders
men who have been sentenced to spend the
rest of their lives
in prison these men helped me reframe my
mind set around manhood
and they instilled in me all of their
aspirations
and goals in hopes that i would never
return to prison
and that i would serve as their
ambassador to the free world
as i talked i could see the lights
turning on for one prosecutor
who said something i thought was obvious
that i had transformed
despite my incarceration and not because
of it
it was clear these prosecutors hadn't
thought much about what happens to us
after they win a conviction
but through this simple process of
seeing in the classroom these lawyers
started to see
that keeping us locked up didn't benefit
our community
or us toward the end of the course
the prosecutors were excited as we
talked about our plans for life after
being released
but they hadn't realized how rough it
was actually going to be
i can literally still see the shock on
one of the junior ada's face
when it hit her the temporary id given
to us
without freedom displayed that we were
just released from prison
she hadn't imagined how many barriers
this would create for us as we ran to
society
but i could also see her genuine empathy
for the choice we had to make between
coming home to a bed in a shelter
or a couch in a relative's overcrowded
apartment
what we learned in the class worked his
way into concrete policy recommendations
we presented our proposals to the state
department of corrections commissioner
and to the manhattan d.a at our
graduation
in the pac columbia auditorium
a team i couldn't have imagined a more
memorable way
to conclude our eight weeks together and
just 10 months after coming home from
prison
i again found myself in a strange room
invited by the commission of nypd to
share my perspective
at a policing summit and while speaking
i recognized the familiar face in the
audience
it was the attorney who prosecuted my
case
seeing him i thought about our days
in the courtroom seven years earlier
as i listened to him recommend a long
prison sentence
as if my young life was meaningless
and had no potential but this time
the circumstances were different i shook
off my thoughts
and walked over to shake his hand
he looked happy to see me surprised
but happy
he acknowledged how proud he was about
being in that room with me and we began
a conversation about working together to
improve the conditions of our community
and so today i carry all of these
experiences with me
as i develop the justice ambassadors
youth council at columbia university
bringing young new yorkers some who've
already spent time locked up
and others who are still enrolled in
high school together with city officials
and in this classroom everyone will
brainstorm ideas
about improving the lives of our city's
most vulnerable youth
before they get trapped within the
criminal justice system
this is possible if we do the work
our society and justice system has
convinced us
that we can lock up our problems and
punish our way out of social challenges
but that's not real imagine with me for
a second
a future where no one can become a
prosecutor
a judge a cop
or even a parole officer without first
sitting in a classroom
to learn from and connect with the very
people whose lives will be in their
hands i'm doing my part to promote the
power of conversations
and the need for collaborations
it is through education that we will
arrive at a truth that is inclusive
and unites us all in the pursuit of
justice
for me it was a brand new conversation
and a new kind of classroom that showed
me how both my mindset
and our criminal justice system could be
transformed
they say the truth so
set you free but i believe
it's education and communication
thank you